In today's episode of Free Pilot
Training, I'm going to explain what you
need to know as a private pilot about
GPS navigation.
Calling safe position.
With today's technology, you've probably
used GPS navigation quite a bit before
getting into aviation. But, because we
fly our airplanes above the ground, and
once you get your instrument rating, you
could potentially fly through clouds,
it's a little bit more complicated than
what you're used to. Now, as you
probably already know, GPS stands for
Global Positioning System, and this is a
complicated system that uses satellites
to help us find our position on the
globe. And it does this through a
process known as trilateration. And the
way this works is that the GPS satellite
sends a signal to your airplane. Then it
calculates the time it takes for that
signal to get there. Once it calculates
the time, then it knows the exact
distance you are from the station. But,
your location could be anywhere 360°
from the satellite, and this is what we
refer to as a time solution. You won't
be able to know your exact position with
a time solution from only one satellite.
But, with a time solution from other
satellites, the GPS system can quickly
narrow down your position. So, we need
to be in range of multiple satellites in
order for the system to accurately do
this. Our GPS constellation has 24
satellites that orbit the entire Earth.
And no matter where you are on the
globe, your equipment should be able to
receive a signal from five different
satellites. With that in mind, in order
to get an accurate two-dimensional
position, your GPS receiver needs to be
locked on to at least three different
satellites. This allows the GPS receiver
to give us our position in latitude and
longitude. It also allows the equipment
to track our movement. And because our
aircraft fly above the Earth's surface,
three GPS satellites are no longer
enough to give us an accurate position
report. To make sure we're receiving an
accurate position, we need four
satellites, and this gives us latitude,
longitude, and altitude. But, even with
four satellites, sometimes these signals
can get corrupted, and this can cause
our GPS system to be less accurate. To
keep this from happening, some GPS
receivers have a special capability that
allows them to monitor the integrity of
the GPS signal. This capability is known
as RAIM, and that stands for receiver
autonomous integrity monitoring. Now, in
order for RAIM to make sure that you're
getting a good signal on all the
satellites, you have to have five
satellites visible to the GPS receiver.
On the other hand, if your airplane has
baro-aiding, you only need four for RAIM
in this case. I don't want to get too
far in the weeds here. You're going to
learn more about this when you go for
your instrument rating. Another way we
can double-check our GPS signal is
through satellite-based augmentation
systems, or SBAS. The one we use here in
the US is called WAAS, the wide area
augmentation system. This system uses
ground-based equipment, which is placed
in precise locations across the country.
These are called wide area reference
stations. In the simplest terms, these
things take a measurement of your
aircraft's location, then they take that
information and send it over to a master
station. Correction information is then
sent up to the satellite, so you're
getting the most accurate position
possible. In addition to that, these
things act somewhat like a ground-based
satellite, which greatly improves the
availability of the GPS signal. Now,
you're probably wondering why I'm
telling you all this, because you're
just getting your private pilot's
license right now. And the reason is, if
you haven't checked RAIM, or your GPS
doesn't have WAAS, this line might not
be as accurate as what you might think.
So, until you learn how to do that, you
need to take what you see on these
screens with a grain of salt. And the
same goes for GPSs that don't have RAIM
or WAAS capability. These GPSs are for
VFR flight only. All right, so I've got
a little homework assignment for you.
Next time you get in the plane, I want
you to ask your instructor how to check
RAIM on the GPS in your airplane. It
should only take a minute or so to do
this, and this is going to really build
a foundation for you when you start
flying instruments. Just remember, if
you have WAAS in the airplane you're
flying, you don't need to check RAIM.
All that stuff kind of happens
automatically. All right, guys. I hope
your instructor already told you this,
but to pass your checkride, you need to
know how to use all the equipment
installed on your airplane. Because of
that, I'm going to go over the basics of
how to use 99% of aviation GPSs out
there. There's really only two buttons
that a private pilot needs to know how
to use. First is called the direct two
button. This is the guy that looks like
a bow and arrow. And the other one is
the nearest button. These two buttons
are available on almost every aviation
GPS out there. To use the direct two
function, I use the mantra direct enter
enter. Start by hitting the direct two
button. Then, you can dial or type in
the airport you want to go to. You can
also go direct to GPS waypoints, which
have five letter identifiers. You can
find these on the VFR sectional, and
you'll be using these a lot more when
you go for your instrument rating. And
you can also dial in VORs, which have
three letter identifiers. Once you've
made your selection, you can hit the
enter button twice. On some GPSs, you
only have to hit the enter button once,
but after you do this, it'll draw a line
right where you want to go. Pretty basic
stuff, right? Next, we have the nearest
button. When you hit this button, the
GPS allows you to select or scroll
through the nearest airports to your
location. Once you make your selection,
you can hit direct enter enter just like
in the previous example. And as you
might have guessed, this button can come
in very handy in an emergency or if you
need to divert for some reason. And
unfortunately, diverting procedures are
a lesson that I don't think is focused
on enough, but the nearest button is by
far the best tool you have available to
you in that situation. Let's talk about
a couple more things that you need to
know if you want to use the GPS
navigation system safely. In order to
use these to fly IFR, these need to be
updated every 28 days. And that's
because aeronautical data is constantly
changing. There could be anything from
new towers to new restricted areas, all
kinds of different changes to the
airspace that you're used to flying in.
Now, maybe you already know about this
restricted area and you always fly the
same route just south of the airspace to
go get your $100 hamburger every
Saturday. If they made this airspace
bigger for some reason and you didn't
update your GPS, you could easily bust
this airspace and not even know it.
Until you got a phone call from the FAA.
So, you can see how it's a good idea to
update your GPS even if you're flying
VFR. And while you legally don't have to
update the GPS for VFR flights, you
should check your route of flight with
an updated VFR sectional before you fly
without an updated GPS. And that'll help
you keep stuff like that from happening.
And in most cases, we can update these
GPS databases ourselves without making
an entry in the maintenance logbook. All
right, so one more thing that might
affect the accuracy of your GPS is the
location of your GPS antenna. Now, on
airplanes with panel-mounted IFR GPSs,
you'll usually find the antenna on top
of the airplane. This allows the GPS to
get a clear, unobstructed signal from
the satellite. But on handheld VFR GPSs
like this one, you usually have to mount
them using a suction cup to the window
or somewhere on the dash. And this can
also cause your GPS to give you an
inaccurate position. Now, I hope I
didn't scare you off in regards to GPS
navigation. GPS is an awesome tool, but
it has limitations and now you kind of
know what those are. And with the
information from this video, now you can
check to make sure you're getting an
accurate position from your GPS. If
you've learned something from today's
video, I'd really appreciate it if you
hit that like button. Then once you do
that, you should check out this video to
keep on studying.
Your blood line, same position.